en 1997 la france découvre ryanair une
compagnie aérienne irlandaise pas cher
ryanair mais pas vraiment réglementaire
au début c'est la promesse de s'envoyer
en l'air pour trois fois rien 400 francs
l'aller-retour entre beauvais et dublin
77 euros nous coûte moins cher d'aller
faire un week-end à dublin que d'aller
passer un week-end à toulouse ou à
perpignan
la recette au début décollé depuis des
aéroports éloignés des villes moins
taxés et des services à bord payants
comme la collation les passagers ne sont
pas car on leur offre la possibilité de
se rendre à paris pour un prix très bas
dans ses premières années ryanair se
développe très vite en france 27 liaison
en 1999 et pour appâter les clients
la compagnie mise sur des coups de com
exemple en alsace en 2002 avec un vol
inaugural entre londres et strasbourg
on n'a rien payer du tout un brin de la
france donne des clients à ryanair
ryanair lui donne des touristes la
compagnie est sur un petit nuage
c'est que ryanair est très rentable nous
opérons depuis 18 ans et aujourd'hui
notre valeur en bourse a atteint le
double de celle d'air france lui c'est
michael o'leary le pdg de ryanair
il a l'air très sérieux comme ça à la
tribune mais c'est un as de la provoc
en 2009 il annonce des vols plus cher
pour les obèses un accès aux toilettes
payants et des avions pour passagers
debout des annonces sans suite
mais là où michael o'leary n'est pas
très réglo c'est avec le droit français
en 2010 les plaintes s'accumulent pour
travail dissimulé charges sociales
payées en irlande et non en france la
solution du pdg de ryanair fermé les
lignes nous sommes convaincus que le
droit français ne nous laisse aucune
autre alternative n'allons pas attendre
encore un an et 18 mois et devoir faire
face à une amende plus et finalement
ryanair a rouvert sa ligne tout juste
trois mois après depuis les conditions
de travail des employés ne se sont pas
vraiment améliorées
les mouvements de grève se multiplient
et conséquence chaque année des
centaines de vols sont annulés
[Musique]